In this section, we're going to talk about level snapshots
with virtual production and looking at that in an ICP
effect scenario.
So let's get started.
Some of the things we'll cover is one, the benefit,
setting it up, and the breakdown.
And I'll run you through each one of these
and how level snapshots is pretty revolutionary
and really great to work with
in a virtual production setting.
One of the first things we need to do
is make sure that it's on within our plugins
and that our icon is available
up at the top of our Unreal workspace.
So let's go ahead and go to Unreal
and take a look at that.
And we're going to talk about how to get that started.
So in Unreal, we want to make sure
that our plugins are set up for level snapshot.
Now, if you're using an ICP effects scenario template,
you more than likely should have that available,
but not all the time.
It just depends what scene you're inheriting.
And also, if your scene was not initially
set up for level for ICP effects,
you do want to check this.
And the primary way to check this
is to see this take a snapshot for level snapshot icon.
You need to see that this is available.
And if you don't see this,
then you need to go into your plugins
and we're going to type in level snapshot.
Make sure it's not unnecessarily capitalized.
And you want to find level snapshots and turn that on.
So this tool is amazing
when it comes to your workflow
and be able to show different lighting scenarios.
And for the helpful part of working with Lumen now,
it makes it so that you can actually show
different lighting scenarios with the real-time updates
with that movable light that's set into your scene.
Normally, in earlier versions of ICP effects
and virtual production,
you would have to bake out your lighting,
have different scenarios that you would screen those levels
and show them to your director and other people,
or have to do the bake on set.
If changes were needed immediately,
you would have to use GPU light mass baking.
But now, because Lumen has been optimized with 5.1,
we're able to actually see the differences
as we move the light around in real time,
and we can capture that information and the changes
and have different scenarios for level snapshot,
which is pretty awesome.
And with Lumen being optimized,
it's pretty revolutionary to be able to do that.
So let's go ahead and open up level snapshot.
Now, to be able to create your level snapshot,
one, we can build it within our browser here.
You can even quickly take a picture of it
or use the pull down to open up
the level snapshot editor.
I've created, I've right clicked here
to be able to make my level snapshot interface here.
I've right clicked, and I've chosen level snapshot,
and I've built a level snapshot template
where I can house all my different snapshots in here.
I can double click on this,
and then now if I want to, I can take it from here.
This is kind of my preferred way of working,
where I can get it built, know exactly where it's at,
and from here, I can take my level snapshots.
From there, I can start using the icons
or any other available resources that I have.
In my level snapshot, in here, I can say,
I want to take this first scene here,
this nice generic layout,
and I'm going to click on take level snapshot.
Here, I can give a description
of exactly what this snapshot is.
We can say scene one on the beach,
not the breach, but the beach.
No military is striking the beach right now.
And we're going to say create level snapshot.
There we go.
And it gives me a actual image of that level snapshot.
Now we're connected to Perforce,
so it's asking me, hey, are you going to make changes here?
And I can create those changes,
and I can mark something for add later.
So this level snapshot is ready to go.
Once I check out this level snapshot that's in here,
we should be okay with keeping our stuff intact.
It will also give us a list off to the right
of exactly the actors that we have in place
within this level.
This is really beneficial and great
because it will actually keep track of your changes.
Now I'm going to go ahead and move my light downwards,
rotate it to give myself more of an evening look and feel.
This is dramatically different than what we just had.
I'm going to take a little snapshot of that.
We'll call this evening, beach evening,
and I'll say create level snapshot.
Now again, this is just the description.
Create level snapshot.
There we go.
So if I want to view these ones, I can double click on it,
and you can get Unreal to restore that level snapshot.
Let's try that again.
We'll say restore level snapshot,
and it goes back to our original.
Double click on the one that we have for the evening,
restore level snapshot, and it shows me the changes.
And this is great to be able to have this on stage
and show this to your director,
as well as in your virtual art department
where people can actually see
and preview things ahead of time.
Let's create one more,
and we can actually see how cool this is.
In 5.1, this has been optimized to have less
of a memory imprint on your whole overall project,
which makes things a lot cleaner to work with
and makes it so that things will load faster,
and it isn't so heavy having all these set up
in your scene.
I'm going to go in here and actually grab a light.
We'll do a simple point light.
Bring it into the scene.
Make sure that it's movable because we are using Lumen.
That way, our baking light option doesn't pop up.
Move this over, move it down,
and I'll move it a little bit closer to that wet rock.
Move down the ground.
There we go.
Now, I'm going to take a level snapshot of that.
We'll call this beach underscore small light shot.
Create level snapshot.
Now, all three of these have been made
with different lighting scenarios.
I can double-click on the one we previously had.
It'll tell me to restore level snapshot, and I'll say yes.
I can go to the one we just made,
double-click on that, restore level snapshot,
and there we go.
Now, if you do get some errors in here,
go and move your light around, and it should update,
and you won't necessarily have to take a level snapshot.
That's just a small refresh issue
that may occur every once in a while.
And again, we're working with Lumen,
and our light is movable, so we can correct those things.
You can also add filters and filter groups
if you need them, allowing you to actually pick
and choose what you need in your scene,
and you can save those filter groups.
Now, normally, some may or may not like
the filter group option, but it is there for you
if you need them, especially if you have lots of shots.
It's really up to you.
And then when you choose these filter groups,
and say we'll choose one if we wanted to filter
by static mesh, by skeletal mesh,
you can filter by name, you can choose what name you want
for that particular item, and in that item,
you can actually determine how those filters
are gonna be reactive to what your searches
are going to be, so you actually can categorize things
according to your customized filters that you've built.
There's also favorite filters here
that you can actually create.
And again, the nice thing about working with these,
and let's go back to one of our scenarios here,
restore the level.
As you select these levels, and I'll get rid
of this filter, you can also get rid of them
if you don't need them.
If you select these levels, you can actually see
what is being changed and what's been added
to your different items, which we mentioned earlier.
You can also look at your settings here.
If I click on our settings, we can find out
exactly how our level snapshot's being handled,
and you can handle your performance if you need to.
Pretty great to be able to do so.
Now, Unreal you saw, if you looked really good,
it's waiting for us to check out the file,
so we can actually do that too.
It's kinda nice to be able to have those options
as you're working.
So in our stage at the top, we'll show us
all the different items that we have in place,
which is really convenient as you're working
within this area, and we can also refresh results.
If you've made any changes or you've done any searching,
you can actually do that really quickly.
You can show or hide your input panel if it's in the way,
and again, we can go back to our original level snapshot.
And again, as you select these, you'll see,
before I even restore, I can see what the changes are
listed again on the side, and I really wanna emphasize this
because this helps you with tracking.
I know I've mentioned it several times,
but keep that in mind because then you can see,
well, do I really need to open this particular level
before you hit restore level snapshot?
That's it for level snapshot.
I hope you enjoyed this section of the course.
What we're going to do in the next part
is we're going to see all this activated on the wall,
and we're gonna see ourselves have remote control
and use the remote control preset
to control some of these items.